FERGUS HURLEY: Hi,
I'm Fergus Hurley,
a product manager at Google.
I'm going to show you how to
use Android vitals to keep
an eye on your app's
engineering performance metrics
so you can fix any problems
that may affect your users.
Why is it important to track
your engineering metrics?
Because when your app
performs badly, users notice.
In fact, almost half of one-star
reviews on the Play Store
mention performance
issues, like app stability.
On the other hand, when
things are running smoothly,
users are happy.
Android vitals tracks
the metrics that
matter most to your users--
battery use, stability,
rendering, startup time,
and permission requests.
Let's start with battery
use, because it's probably
the most important of all.
Nobody wants to use an app
that drains their battery.
So Android vitals reports on
the four most significant causes
of battery drain--
wake locks, wakeups,
background Wi-Fi scans,
and background network use.
Background partial
wake locks are
when your app keeps the CPU
running after the device's
display turns off.
It can become stuck, if
it's held for a long time
while your app runs
in the background.
This can drain the
user's battery.
So you should use them
sparingly and release them
as soon as possible.
The second cause of battery
drain is excessive wakeups.
These let your app
wake up a device
at a certain time, bringing
it out of low-power mode,
and holding a partial wake
lock, while the alarm executes.
Again, these can drain
your user's battery.
And you want to use them
as little as possible.
The last two battery-related
metrics we track
are excessive background
Wi-Fi scans and network use.
In both cases, your app
connects to the internet
in the background,
waking up the CPU
and turning on the radio, which
is draining the user's battery.
If your app doesn't use
any of these features,
then you will not see
metrics in vitals for them.
Also, if your app does not have
enough users above the privacy
threshold, then you will
not see any data either.
So now that we've
covered battery life,
the next most important area
of Android vitals to focus on
is app stability.
We track two stability metrics,
ANR events and crashes.
Application Not
Responding, or ANR events,
are when your app stops
responding to user input.
This happens when the
UI thread of the app
is blocked for too
long, so the user's app
appears to freeze on them.
Crashes occur when an unhandled
exception or signal causes
your app to exit unexpectedly.
Of course, you'll want to keep
both of these to a minimum.
Your Android vitals
dashboard also
displays your app's
rendering metrics.
Users want a fast,
responsive application
that runs smoothly and
doesn't lag or stall.
So we track any instances
of slow rendering
or frozen frames.
Slow rendering is when your
app can't render frames
in under 16 milliseconds.
When this happens, your
app appears to stutter.
We call it jank.
Frozen frames occur
when UI frames
take longer than 700
milliseconds to render.
This makes your app appear stuck
and unresponsive to user input
for almost a second.
Users also expect your
app to launch quickly.
On your Android
vitals dashboard,
you can easily identify when
your app is loading slowly
with different metrics for
cold starts, warm starts,
and hot starts.
A cold start is
when your app hasn't
been launched for a while and
isn't in the device's memory.
This means the device needs to
create and start all your apps
resources to get it running.
In this case, a slow start
would mean 5 seconds or more.
A warm start is when
your app is in memory
and simply needs
to go from activity
launched to activity running.
In this case, a slow start
would be 2 seconds or more.
Finally, a hot start is when
your app and its activity
are in memory and your
app goes from on restart
to activity running.
From a hot start, your
app shouldn't take longer
than 1.5 seconds to load.
The last metric
in your dashboard
is all about permissions.
Here, you'll see the
percentage of people
who are denied a permission
request made by your app.
If the level is
high, you may need
to explain the reason
for your request
or rethink whether you actually
need that permission at all.
So how do know if
your metrics are good?
On the dashboard, you'll see
benchmarks for each vital
to help you understand how
your app or game is performing
and which issues, if
any, to prioritize.
For example, people expect
board games to load faster
than racing games.
So your metrics will only be
measured against similar apps.
Not sure what to focus on first?
Well, all your metrics
are important to monitor.
We've highlighted the
four most important ones
on your Android
vitals dashboard--
ANR rate, crash rate, stock
wake locks in the background,
and excessive wakeups.
We call these the core vitals.
Hopefully, your apps
metrics all look good.
But if something
should go wrong,
it's important to fix the
problem as quickly as possible.
That's why Android vitals also
provides anomaly detection.
Just click on the
dashboard alert
to learn more about the problem.
Or you can sign up for
Anomaly Alerts emails.
Addressing these issues
as quickly as possible
not only keeps your
users happy, it also
helps improve your app's
profile in the Play Store,
such as it's discoverability
in the search results.
Android vitals
gives you the tools
to monitor your
app's performance
and keep it running smoothly.
For more advice on how
to address app issues,
check out our videos on
stability and battery life.
You'll find the links in
the video description.
To learn more about Android
vitals and the rest of the Play
Console or for tips on how to
grow your app or game business,
check out the Playbook
app on Google Play.
Thanks for watching.